en que nos deux nouveaux invités
s'installent je vous présente leur
circonscription il s'agit de la deuxième
du territoire de belfort
c'est le nord du département en fait et
vous allez voir les résultats cette
circonscription a placé en tête le
candidat de la république en marche
bruno kern avec quasiment 30% des
suffrages le député udi sortant michel
zumkeller est à 23 et demi un peu plus
de six points derrière donc nos deux
finalistes sont en plateau bonsoir à
vous deux bruno kern il s'agit pour vous
d'un retour en politique retour gagnant
en tout cas dimanche dernier pour le
premier tour vous lancez un socialiste
l'ancien premier adjoint à la mairie de
belfort quasiment un tiers des électeurs
a choisi le bulletin à votre nom vous
considérez avoir bénéficié à plein de la
vague mâcon d'abord je remercie les
électeurs de la circonscription de
l'avoir fait deuxièmement j'ai une envie
de dire une surprise dans la mesure où
et en face un député sortant celui ci a
naturellement une image plus forte qu'un
nouveau candidat et c'est donc à la fois
le travail de terrain parce que nous
avons été très nombreux avec moi même
sur ce terrain de la seconde
circonscription pour aller convaincre
et en plus il y a bien entendu et au
premier chef le fait que je suis le
référent départemental des manuels
macron depuis plus d'un an que j'ai
rejoint à un moment où personne ne
pensait qu'il serait candidat et qu'il
gagnerait vous avez eu des mandats
précédemment je le disais que répondez
vous non un mandat je me permets de dire
le premier adjoint jamais vécu de la
politique jamais êtes avocat je le
précise et que répondez vous aux
critiques qui accusent la république en
marche notamment en franche comté de
recycler des socialistes ou des anciens
socialistes je ne parlerai pas pour les
autres
je dirais simplement en ce qui me
concerne
à l'issue du premier mandat que j'ai
fait deux premiers adjoints au maire de
belfort et premier vice président de
l'agglomération
je n'ai pas voulu repartir avec l'équipe
à laquelle j'appartenais parce que
j'étais en total désaccord avec la
dérive deux pas du parti socialiste qui
je pense est allé le mener à la déroute
ça fait donc trois ans que je sois et
que j'ai
je suis 100 sans engagement encartés
comme on dit et c'est au bout de trois
ans parce que emmanuel macron est arrivé
que j'ai décidé de reprendre entre
guillemets du service michel zink alors
vous êtes donc le député sortant il ya
cinq ans dans un contexte où françois
hollande venait d'être élu président de
la république défavorable pour vous qui
appartenez à un parti de centre droit je
le rappelle vous étiez en tête du
premier tour 30% des suffrages là vous
êtes deuxièmes 23 et demi à quoi
attribuez-vous cette contre-performance
je pense qu'il ya plusieurs raisons il
ya une vague manifeste très clairement
il ya aussi une abstention incroyable un
monsieur qu'hermes dit gg représenter
30% au nom il représente 30% de 50 ce
qui est tout à fait la même chose et
c'est pareil moi on est bien d'accord
tous les deux donc c'est pour ça que
effectivement toute façon c'est une
déception j'ai aucun aucun souci
là-dessus je crois que d'après déception
c'est qu'on a pas su convaincre les
électeurs du theater de belfort comme
ailleurs de se mobiliser c'est ce qu'on
est en train de faire cette semaine en
expliquant vraiment les choses mais il
ya eu aussi une campagne un petit peu
comme la présidentielle c'est à dire on
rentre pas dans le fond des choses on
espère juste qu on a un président jeune
ce qui est vrai qui fait en trois
semaines un petit peu de représentations
et tout va bien
fort heureusement et je vous en remercie
cette semaine nous sommes dans le vif du
sujet avec des programmes et là nous
avons espoir que nos concitoyens face au
programme proposé par monsieur qu elles
et elles sont passées parce que il un
petit problème est que les chiffres y
compte un mandat lui un premier adjoint
et un mandat premier vice président pour
lui ça fait un seul mandat
il a eu deux mandats ce qui est tout à
fait respectable mais ses deux mandats à
monsieur excellent député maire de
val-d'or acquis 17,1 des guerres
d'accord mais moi j'ai voté contre la
loi qui cumule donc j'assume totalement
ma position
simplement quand j'ai eu deux mandats je
dis je demande à monsieur kern a eu deux
mandats il dit qu'il a eu un mandat
c'est pas tout à fait un jeu michel
zumkeller vous êtes en lice pour un
quatrième mandat d'un député consécutif
n'est ce pas trop n'y at il pas tout
simplement en effet d'usure côté l'euro
moi je suis très surpris que pendant
cette campagne
la seule chose qu'on m'a reproché c'est
de faire un quatrième mandat on aurait
pu me dire t'as pas fait le boulot on
aurait pu me dire tu corresponds pas aux
règles de moralisation et certainement à
aucun moment la seule chose que me dit
monsieur kahn s'est tu fais un quatrième
mandat
les électeurs dimanche pour choisir moi
j'ai un bilan j'ai un petit peu je pense
quand même que quand on parle il faut
que l'homme politique qui soit il n'est
pas donné mais pas travailler moi j'ai
arrêté mon travail quand on dit l'homme
politique qui doit être honnête il doit
être clair il doit être clean surtout je
le suis depuis 15 ans quand on dit doit
être à l'écouté je suis aussi donc moi
je n'ai pas de souci avec ça
je constate simplement que la seule
chose que me reproche mon adversaire
c'est de faire un quatrième mandat
c'est dans une entreprise quand vous
avez 15 ans d'expérience et 51 ans on
n'estime pas que vous êtes trop vieux on
estime qu'il ya une expérience à
valoriser c'est ce que je propose à mes
concitoyens et choisiront choisir je
précise en plus bruno kern son je veux
pas vous heurtez mais vous êtes plus âgé
que michel zumkeller tout on est
d'accord
voilà tout à fait ce qui me permettra
plus facilement que lui si je suis élu
député de me consacrer entièrement à mon
mandat je vois pas pourquoi j'ai arrêté
toute activité professionnelle depuis 15
ans très clairement j'étais artisan je
ne suis plus ça fait quinze ans que tous
les jours je suis sur le terrain je ne
conteste pas mais je vous permets plein
de choses mais pas de dire que je me
suis investi à chauny je ne conteste pas
je m'appelle seychelles lorsque n'est
pas mon modèle c'est sympathique
je voudrais simplement je sais pas la
peine de faire devant les électeurs un
numéro qui n'existe pas on s'appelle par
nos prénoms et on se tutoie et on se
voit depuis des années on a pigé à
l'agglomération sont messieurs qu'un ne
racontons pas d'histoires fait aux
électeurs s'il faut je reviendrai
maturité dans les positions nationales
devaient galère comme monsieur monsieur
zoom keller veut bien laisser parler
allez-y et puis on fait circuler sur je
ne lui reproche rien je constate
simplement qu'il y a cinq ans il a pris
un engagement devant les élus les maires
et devant ses électeurs en disant que ce
serait le dernier mandat
et aujourd'hui il veut en faire un peu
plus pour être député pendant 20 ans
c'est par proches c'est une constatation
est par ailleurs on laisse répondre sur
vous avez changé la vie non tout donc
monsieur pierre nadeau créé un doute à
me reprocher un g6 là dessus j'ai très
clairement changé la vie parce que je
pense que je peux encore être utile
parce que j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur
les lois antiterroristes
parce que j'ai travaillé sur beaucoup de
choses parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
encore à faire mais de toute façon je
suis pas en train de motos proclamé
c'est les électeurs qui vont choisir
c'est eux qui choisiront s'ils
s'estiment c'est le modèle trop ils me
le diront et je respecte le choix des
électeurs
évidemment michel jeunes quelle heure
vous souhaitiez parler du fond votre
circonscription à tous les deux habitent
abritent des usines emblématique alstom
general electric il ya aussi tout un
un maillage de villages ruraux avec des
problématiques particulières de quel
dossier
souhaitez vous vous emparez l'un ou
l'autre si vous êtes élue dimanche
prochain pour améliorer le quotidien de
vos électeurs
bruno kern oui au départ je voudrais
écarter définitivement un sujet là qui
revient je ne fais pas campagne en
reprochant quelque chose à mon
adversaire et il y en avait 12 nous
étions là il va vous dire que vous
reveniez parler du fond je vais parler
du fond je dis simplement que
précisément j'ai fait une campagne
positive sur le fond et je ne parle que
du fond accessoirement d'un des
candidats -le j'avais contre - premier
tour mais accessoirement sur les
dossiers de fond vous avez alstom alstom
qui est dans une situation où les
commandes devraient être là où l'emploi
devrait être préservé mais en même temps
les aspects les garanties ne sont pas
encore très claires et les salariés
l'attendent
vous avez également reydel qui est dans
le nord du territoire qui est une
entreprise sur rougegoutte la oumma ma
suppléante marie pierre lévesque qui est
du monde de la rivalité est élu c'est
une entreprise qui est gérée par un
fonds de pension donc à tout moment le
fonds de pension peut considérer que la
rentabilité départ ne sera pas rendez
vous donc vous serez que la majorité
présidentielle à venir interdisent aux
fonds de pension d'entrer dans le
capital des entreprises françaises je
vais vous dire un fonds de pension et
rentrer dans le capital de la société
civile immobilière qui a construites ces
shows celle de general electric et 7 un
fonds de pension hollandais
donc la question n'est pas de savoir si
les fonds de pension doivent ou pas la
question est de savoir si on place la
rentabilité financière avant avant le
fait que des bénéfices doivent permettre
de développer l'emploi et sur ce point
là que nous soyons là où nos députés
nous nous battrons alors moi j'ai la
faiblesse de penser que
les salariés d'alstom n'ont pas eu la
mémoire courte puisque j'ai été l'avocat
qui a permis aux salariés d'alstom de
bénéficier du plan amiante avec un
départ anticipé à la retraite de trois
ans michel zumkeller quels dossiers pour
améliorer le quotidien as sir conseille
évidemment que l'emploi c'est la presse
est la priorité
moi j'ai fait ces cinq gardés dans
l'opposition et on s'est battu pendant
cinq ans parce que le gouvernement
précédent
il n'a fait que chargé les entreprises
est chargé ceux qui avaient des moyens
et qui était ministre de l'économie
emmanuel macron on peut parler d' alstom
on sait tout de 18 mois avant il était
conseiller du président de république on
peut lui encore 18 mois milices de
l'économie ont fait beaucoup de choses
en presse ou alors il n'a rien fait lui
non plus donc
et là il faut agir là dessus c'est à
dire comment on fait pour améliorer la
compétitivité car l'expriment rare par
exemple aujourd'hui sur le code du
travail vous pas comme ça le code du
travail si on veut changer on fait comme
l'ont fait les pays nordiques on se
réunit partis politiques syndicats on
discute pendant six mois on trouve une
ligne de conduite qui prévient 69
secondes ça discute de croire hippolyte
et bien sûr lesquels ceux qui vont
république et ceux qui vont gagner 10
franc et républicain ce kern a une
faculté à accepter le débat c'est
impressionnant il faut que tout le monde
se mette autour de la table mais
certainement pas avec 450 députés en
marche avec une noix par ordonnance ou
ça sera silence si y'a rien à voir
le code du travail c'est la sphère de
tous les français il faut le boucher
effectivement tout le monde entend et on
ne bougera bien que si on arrive à du
donnant-donnant entreprises salariés
tous les partenaires le sepa l'histoire
de l'oeuf a bien sûr qu'il faut le faire
mais faisons le ensemble dans la
discussion de la négociation et on n'y
arrivera pas avec 450 députés en marché
dans votre parti lui dit centre-droit je
le rappelle parce que pourquoi les gens
qui nous regardent c'est pas forcément
évident généralement on dit jean louis
borloo ça passe bien lors des plus le il
en est encore là mais évidemment oui il
est fondateur c'est lui le créateur du
parti beaucoup de vos collègues à lui
dit on plate change rien à dire sur le
président de la république et sur sa
politique quand il était ministre de
l'économie et sur les projets qu'il
défend aujourd'hui si vous êtes réélu
député dimanche où siégeraient vous
serez vous dans l'opposition où serez
vous un eu des indés et de droite
pro macron
rassurée je serai dans l'opposition
évidemment mais il n'empêche que la
volonté de lui dit qui a toujours été la
même c'est-à-dire quand y ait eu des
bonnes mesures du précédent gouvernement
les a votés
on s'est opposé à n'agir appareils parce
que l'idée c'est pas d'être pour ou
contre le président macron l'idée c'est
pour ou contre la france et nous comme
beaucoup d'hommes politiques
évidemment on sera pour la france donc à
lui dit on n'a pas une position
dogmatique
a beaucoup travaillé avec le président
macro et sas été remis
comment après 45 jours de discussion à
l'assemblée où j'ai été très présent par
le 49-3 circulez ya rien à voir donc si
c'est ça la méthode ça sera pas la bonne
méthode je dis pas ça pour moi ou pour
monsieur kern je dis ça parce que ce
pays a besoin de réformes et pas comme
ça donc c'est effectivement vous avez
cité un bon exemple
lui dit on est partant pour tous pour
tout ce qui sera intéressant pour la
france
alors il ya une particularité dans votre
circonscription quand on regarde les
résultats c'est 40% des électeurs au
premier tour on choisit les candidats du
front national de la france insoumise
d'europe écologie les verts ou du parti
socialiste qu'avez vous à dire à ses
électeurs du premier tour pour les
convaincre de choisir votre bulletin
dimanche prochain bruno calmes j'ai
répondu aujourd'hui et c'est surtout les
réseaux sociaux aux questions que m'ont
posée à moins comme michel zumkeller les
écologistes et je salue d'une certaine
manière le score de 20 cents jeudi qui
est arrivé devant le parti socialiste et
qui est implantée à titre personnel dans
cette circonscription
il sait quel est mon engagement pour
cette cause là je suis puisque vous avez
voulu rappeler que j'ai eu un précédent
mandat
j'étais même en 2008 tête de liste du
parti socialiste et les électeurs s'en
souviendront également et c'est je suis
le premier à avoir fait rentrer les
écologistes à la ville de belfort il dit
sont restés pendant tout le monde a je
leur dis simplement que tous les
engagements que j'ai pris auprès d'eux
je les maintiendrait et que par ailleurs
j'ai le soutien de nicolas hulot tels
qu'ils pourront le voir dans les
prochains jours michelle gellar
c'est très simple moi je ne suis pas
dans le racolage politique d'entre deux
tours ces gens là me connaissent ce que
je vais leur dire c'est ne laissons pas
la majorité à un seul parti qu'il
présenterait 450 450 députés
monsieur macron depuis quelques semaines
et son équipe peut être pas lui
d'ailleurs mais si les gens autour d'eux
ils passent leur temps à humilier les
gens du ps a humilié les gens de
mélenchon à humilier les gens qui votent
front national
nous on veut pas ça on veut dire à tous
ces gens on va encore avoir la
possibilité de construire pas une
majorité on va pas leur mentir mais une
opposition pour que tout le monde trouve
sa place et le parlement ne vivra que
si jamais tout le monde peut s'exprimer
si jamais la majorité trop écrasante
nous n'y arriverons pas michel zumkeller
avant la conclusion carte blanche en 30
secondes
une thématique dont voudriez parler
absolument ou interpeller votre
adversaire sur une question particulière
l'interpeller on a dit l'essentiel de ce
qui pose problème à ses électeurs c'est
le fait qu'il leur a annoncé qu'il ne se
représenterait pas et qui est sûr
présente on y revient par ailleurs n'est
que par ailleurs par ailleurs je crois
beaucoup à la signification des binômes
qui sont constitués je ne dis pas que
votre vidéo met un mauvais binôme
d'autant plus que votre suppléante est
une personne engagée sur le plan social
et c est que le travail qu'elle fournit
et un travail à verser l'apia alors par
contre je m'interroge je suis le seul
jeu l'était au premier tour où je le
suis encore plus au second avoir
constitué un binôme qui donnent la part
totale à la ruralité avec une suppléante
conseillère municipale de rougegoutte et
qui anime le circuit court et garder le
schéma trouvé reste vous pouvez répondre
ou choisir de parler d'autres j'ai pas
de souci avec la ruralité je le vis
depuis des années les maires ruraux
savent que je suis à côté d'eux depuis
quinze ans par contre j'ai une question
moi bien précises parce que monsieur
kern une facilité à tourner autour du
pot vous savez poser moins de questions
j'ai mes réponses
j'ai une question très simple le
président macron veut augmenter la csg
ça représente 25 21 milliards de
rentrées
il nous dit mais c'est pas grave je vais
baisser la taxe d'habitation ça
représente 10 milliards d'économies
ça veut dire que vous prenez au minima
11 milliards chaque année dans la poche
des français
est ce que vous pourriez nous dire là à
ce moment précis dans la poche de quel
français vous prenez ces 11 milliards
les retraités est maintenant on arrive à
la fin du débat
votre calcul n'est pas juste parce qu'en
même temps il ya 3 7% de eu de baisse
des cotisations d'assurance qui font
augmenter de 500 à 1200 euros par an
pour les plus bas salaires qu'ils se
rabattent réponse bruno kern ans on
arrive à ma question on arrive au terme
du débat brune car votre conclusion 30
secondes s'il vous plaît je souhaite que
le territoire de belfort
retrouve une voie non seulement dans le
département mais également au niveau
national je dirais simplement ce que
jean pierre chevènement a dit de moi
lorsqu'il m'a apporté son soutien lui
même qui a été pendant 30 ans député
bruno kern est à même de représenter
valablement cette circonscription niveau
national michel keller votre conclusion
si remarque bruno kern est soutenue par
un député qui a été lieu dix fois et que
ça ne gène pas bruno kern jean pierre
chevènement
ma conclusion est simple depuis 15 ans
je me dévoue quotidiennement pour ce
territoire je suis très heureux c'est ma
passion me dévoue pour ce territoire
- c'est aux électeurs de décider je leur
fais confiance
mais ce qu'on nous demande je veux dire
les luttes proximité les lyonnais tu
sais moi depuis des années donc je veux
incarner ce territoire pas pour moi pour
ce territoire et les gens savent très
bien
la part que j'ai prise en 15 ans ni trop
ni pas assez pour permettre à ce
territoire de se développer
ma seule ambition elle est là vous
estimez que c'est un mandat trop je le
rappelle vous n'avez que ça à me
reprocher pour moi une dernière chance
pour le territoire de belfort et je n'ai
aucun doute sur le choix des habits des
électeurs du territoire de belfort
dimanche prochain merci à tous les deux
tout de suite un nouveau débat
[Musique]